[Music]
thank you
thank you you may now take your seats
ladies and gentlemen at this juncture
may I call on Mr Paulo Duarte
eccp president back on stage to
introduce our keynote speaker
good afternoon once again
it is my distinct honor to invite on
stage on stage Her Excellency Ursula
Wonderland president of the European
commission to deliver a keynote message
welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much president Duarte
chairman Chua
Minister ladies and gentlemen it is very
special for me to be here in Manila
and once again to experience firsthand
the famous Filipino hospitality
each time I visit
I am struck by the warmth
the intelligence
and the honesty of the people I meet
you make everyone really feel at home
even
000 kilometers away from home I really
feel welcomed here and it's I'm very
glad to be here with you
while visiting your beautiful country
I've always I also learned a proverb of
yours it says be like a rice stock
the more grain it Bears the lower it
bows
and I believe a country's Proverbs can
tell a lot about its people
and this proverb certainly describes the
people of the Philippines
always humble
especially in success
right now the Philippines are booming
thanks to your resilience
your dynamism
your work ethics
your economy grew by eight percent last
year
you're among the fastest growing
Emerging Markets
your development plan as outlined by
President Marcos is prioritizing good
governance
cutting red tape
and speeding up permitting for strategic
Investments for example in Renewables
and semiconductors
not only does this make the Philippines
an even more attractive trade and
investment destination for European
firms
but Filipino companies are also
beginning to thrive in the European
Union
IMI for example
has expanded its microelectronics
business
to become the 14th largest manufacturing
solution provider in Europe
or consider the Philippine Port handling
Giant
ictsi
it operates a Container Terminal in the
Adriatic Sea
and recently signed another 30-year
lease to operate a port in the baltics
it's worth mentioning as well that there
are around 50
000 Filipino Sailors Manning ships with
European flags
so you make trade happen
and you never boast about any of this
so allow me to begin by thanking all
Filipinos
who are contributing every single day to
the friendship
and the economic partnership between
Europe and the Philippines
examples show that the ties
between our regions are already strong
but the time has come I think
to lift our partnership
to the next level
because we have much more in common
than our Geographic distance would
suggest
I see three main fields
where we share interests and values
and we are just made to work together
first of all International Security
both the Philippines and Europe believe
in a global order that is based on the
principles of the UN Charter
such as respect for every nation's
sovereignty
and territorial integrity
and this order is now threatened in both
our regions
second economic transformation we are
both modernizing our economies with a
focus
on the green and the digital transition
and in parallel we are de-risking our
trade Investments
Europe and the Philippines are natural
economic Partners more than ever before
and third on democratic values
because economic progress can only be
coupled with social progress for all
people in our societies
let me begin with security
the Philippines have helped to build the
rules-based global order
you were a founding member of the United
Nations
asean
and the World Trade Organization
and last year you stood up
to uphold the global order
when Russia sent its tanks into Ukraine
both the European Union and the
Philippines
along with over 140 countries
have clearly condemned Russia's war of
aggression
Against The Sovereign independent member
of the United Nations
and this is why we Europeans will
continue to support Ukraine and to
uphold the U.N Charter for as long as it
takes
but another permanent member of the U.N
security Council
China
has yet to assume fully its
responsibility under the U.N Charter to
uphold
the sovereignty and territory Integrity
of Ukraine
this is happening against the backdrop
of China's more assertive stance in our
region
Europe has constantly called on China to
respect the Sovereign rights of States
within their exclusive economic zones
China's show of military force in the
South and East China Sea and in the
Taiwan Strait directly affects
Philippines and other partners in the
region
but it could also have Global
repercussions
because any weakening of regional
stability in Asia
the fastest growing region in the world
affects Global Security
the free flow of trade
and our own interests in the region
so whether we talk about Ukraine
or about the South China Sea
our security is connected
and that is why the European Union has
been enhancing its engagement
in the indo-pacific
we aim to promote a free and open
indo-pacific
to reinforce respect of international
law
and address Global challenges
with the Philippines
we are deepening our security
partnership
particularly on Maritime security and on
Cyber cooperation
and we want to do more
ladies and gentlemen we cannot choose
our neighbors
but we can choose who to do business
with
and on what terms
and this leads me to my second point
we Europeans are clear-eyed when it
comes to diversifying
and de-risking our trade and Investments
we made the mistake with Russia thinking
that we could manage our geopolitical
interests through business
just to recall
before the full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
Europe heavily relied on fossil fuel
energy
imports from Russia
then when the Kremlin started the war
Russia tried to Blackmail us with
cutting its gas supply principalips
threatened and then it cut
Russia cut 80 percent of the natural gas
supplies to Europe within eight months
so you can imagine this trade triggered
a severe energy crisis in Europe but we
we stood
we saved energy
20 of the energy the European people
really understood what it was all about
we Diversified to like-minded Partners
like the United States and Norway
algerium Morocco
and we massively invested in renewable
energy
because this is homegrown energy
so for the first time last year
the European Union produced more
electricity from Sun and wind
than from gas
today
we're stronger than before and more
independent
and we have learned our lesson so we
won't make the same mistake again
when it comes to key inputs
needed for our competitiveness
not only energy but for example critical
raw materials
we should never rely on one single
supplier
and this is the core of our de-risking
strategy
and I know this is not only Europe's
the Philippines for instance exports 90
of its nickel ore to China
instead of processing it inside the
country to create more jobs
and added value
but this can change
that's also why I'm here in Manila today
the Philippines and the European Union
have a major opportunity to step up our
partnership on both
trade and investment
so let me focus on investment first
Europe has just launched a plan for
boosting infrastructure investments in
strategic sectors in partner countries
we call it global gateway
and for asean we've put forward an
investment package worth 10 billion
euros in public funds
but it's not only about money
it's also about the method
European Investments come with the
highest environmental and Labor Standard
as well with a strong focus on creating
local value chains
take the raw material example
unlike other foreign investors we do not
want to invest only in the extraction of
raw materials
we can also support you in building
local capacity for processing powered by
new clean energy infrastructure
renewable energy as I said is not only
good for the climate it's also homegrown
so global gateway seeks to create good
jobs right here because this also
strengthen our supply chains
global gateway seeks to promote
Investments that move Filipino sectors
up the value chain
and we look forward to working with the
Asia Development Bank based right here
in Manila
you are the experts in the region and we
share similar priority
so it's only natural that we work hand
in hand
moreover
the Philippines are natural leader in
digital innovation
the Philippine Venture Capital report
observed an explosion
of new activity in the country startup
ecosystem
your e-commerce market value increased
by 33 percent in the last three years
alone
and the people of the Philippines are
five years younger than the global
average
these are huge assets that you have here
so it's no surprise that your economy is
so dynamic
and the Philippines can become a new
digital Hub in the region
but as entrepreneurs everywhere
Filipino entrepreneurs need
infrastructure investment
and this is where global gateway can
truly make a difference
and we are already working on the ground
or I should rather say in space
together with the Philippine space
agency we are building the first
Earth observation system
and in parallel Nokia is investing in 5G
infrastructure
so why does this matter to Filipino
investors
and why does it matter for Filipino
innovators
because the European Copernicus
satellites
and their data will be made available
for space-based services right here in
the Philippines
in other words the Copernicus data will
be in real time stored and shared here
in the Philippines through your space
agency
and this is of utmost importance for
example for this disaster risk
management
or for early Warning Systems against
typhoon the typical topic here for the
Philippines but also for climate change
observation
for satellite navigation which is
fundamental for Aviation for example for
drones at autonomous driving
and this example
is just a part of a larger digital
economy package
that we are finalizing with the
government
we are even and I love this project
exploring a possible extension
of a new fiber submarine cable
that will connect the European Union
via the Arctic
to Japan and now we're looking into the
possibility to extend it to the
Philippines
so we would create a direct data
connection between our two regions
to de-risk and open up new opportunities
for both our economies
new Investments could also lead the way
for more trade between Europe and the
Philippines
the European Union is your first foreign
investor
your fourth largest trading partner
accounting for nearly eight percent of
your trade
and this is thanks to our current trade
preference scheme the so-called GSP plus
which we will prolong
but there's much more untapped potential
in our trade relationship
and let me give you an example
a few months ago I was in South Korea
there I saw the impressive positive
impact of a trade deal we've just
concluded
in a little over a decade the EU trade
with Korea has more than doubled
and this is what happens when you give
people and businesses the opportunity to
work across borders
new doors open for innovation
and most importantly people benefit
so let's make progress
trade agreements with Singapore and
Vietnam are already delivering
and Europe wants to conclude more free
trade agreement with other asean
countries
I believe like President Marcos
that the timing
and the conditions are just right for us
now
to solidify our bilateral trade
relations
and that is why we have taken the
decision to relaunch our negotiations
for a free trade agreement between the
Philippines and the European Union
[Applause]
trade agreements today are about much
more than eliminating tariffs and quotas
they are about shared commitments values
and principles
including on human and labor rights
and this leads me to the last point
our democracies
all of them are work in progress
none of them is perfect
but all of them are perfectable
your new government has taken some
important steps for human rights here in
the Philippines
each one of our democracies is different
but we all share
the same Universal values
and the same direction of trouble
the path towards better democracies is
one that we can and we should walk
together
ladies and gentlemen
the Philippines and the European Union
May stand at the opposite sides of the
world
but our destinies are linked more than
ever before
we see it with geopolitics
and climate change
we see it in the connection of our value
chains
we have a similar Outlook in the
indo-pacific
and we have strong economic ties
Europe wants to be a trusted partner to
the Philippines
as it grows into its economic potential
we want to be partners who stand eye to
eye
Partners who put people
and their values first
having met so many wonderful people here
in the Philippines
who are proud of their country
hard working
and humble
I'm excited for what we can achieve
together
I know you are proud of your bayanihan
spirit
and I really hope
that we can build the Same Spirit of
community between us in Europe and the
Philippines
salamat and thank you very much for
inviting me thank you very much
[Applause]
Madame President may we ask you to stay
on stage
[Applause]
um
this is going to look like a Philippine
wedding which is the picture taking part
so we're going to do it in two batches
It's usually the Brides family and the
groom's family but this time we'll start
with batch number one
speakers heads of organizers and guests
of honor from the Philippine government
secretary Pascual
and our esteemed panelists please come
here on stage and join us for a family
photo
[Music]
okay
it isn't over yet Madame press